this is a giant centipede in Mexico
Sonoran desert when this critter gets
hungry it seeks out prey with its
antennae it can paralyze and kill using
the poison claws on the underside of its
head it mostly dines on bugs but we'll
go after larger meals up to an including
grasshopper mice like this one the giant
centipede finds the babies especially
delectable easily devouring one by
itself
the centipede is on the prowl the
grasshopper mice are ready and willing
to defend their young just how evil they
are we'll soon find out
the adult lice take up battle stations
who Wade's into the fray half the female
of course it takes all the agility she's
got to avoid the centipedes venomous
fangs imagine a kung fu film starring a
giant centipede and a grasshopper mouse
it would probably look something like
this
you've got to admit that Mouse mom has
got serious game
she finally whips the centipede while
the male looks on no doubt who the
warrior is in this family the mouse
nibbles on the dead centipede turns out
this battle was never in question
rosamma mice are simply the superior
predator back in the nest the warrior
queen turns back into just play mob